okay hello to people joining this live
stream we are talking about our
initiative in multi-computation
and
looks like nick has some things to
demonstrate here
um
so just basically a few more
new examples because i
refactor this object
almost from scratch
okay so let's understand what this
object is so multi
what is what is it doing here
this is a
like a holder for a bunch of rules and
options right now
you give it an expression and you can
give it an expression and a list of
explicit rules
that's one of the things that you can do
and on those
okay i'm i'm very confused here so this
is an unevaluated version of this thing
can it does it um
does it just run here oh yeah because
you've got a
thing
there
yeah
okay so what's it doing now is it trying
to run to a fixed point
oh
come on
let's take a look here
how do i see what it is
oh wait a minute page unavailable
it's trying to go to the generic
function repository is it there or is it
not there
no it's not there can you try this one
we can just
take the
code in the multicomputation folder
what
what happened here
failed to find resource so that's a
cloud object
can you just say cloud get or something
or maybe it's private
no i'm i'm pulling up that page as a web
page
but this isn't this doesn't look like
it's the right kind of page
that's not the resource object
it does say function resource
so it's a resource it's a resource
function
without documentation it's just a raw
function
okay
on that page try pressing the copy
button to copy the link
like press on the thing says multi
doesn't that doesn't that copy it i
wonder what it copies
basically the same thing
maybe nick if you could if you could run
like set permissions on it or something
although it does look like it's public
oh it's a it's a perfectly published
function maybe it's a new prototype
thing i don't know
hold on hold on
okay wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute let me let me not confuse
everything by doing that
okay let me not do that
here let me just take this and run an
existing build
okay we may just have wasted our time
here because that was probably
a pure
um
okay let me take this
that's probably a 13 one bug
probably should get reported but but
um well your build was from like two
weeks ago also
the thirteen one built really
it said march 29th oh come on
this is failing too
it says page unavailable when i click
that
it says page unavailable
so that seems like that's
so why don't you get the cloud get the
correct address from the zoom chat and
try doing it in the correct build
okay i think there's a permissions
problem
also just not to use quad called object
and
just a stream can you give it a stream
because i'm just publishing it it's
publishing without permission as a
public by default so
um
i guess
okay
can you say
options of that comma permissions or you
can only nick do that
i don't think i can find that out
or we can just evaluate the code itself
it's in the multi notebook
as we did previous time
which where is that notebook is the in
the multicomputation
yep
okay great
hopefully those resource functions gonna
work but it depends on just delete all
the initialization cells
okay those are fetching fine
okay
so now
define resource function
is that what we want
well okay is this i don't know did that
do the right thing or
now what should i do over here
i'll just replace with multi
just don't use a box
okay what did that just do
right now just
tried my multi-repost function on this
object
with those rules
and all the matches that it found just
stores them
and then you can just query it with a
bunch of properties like you can
evaluate it
it will give you
like try multi
open bracket validate string
variable as
a property
if you save it to a variable you have to
wrap it in an oblique
or it will do it like this it ate the
set
yeah it needs the set because it
doesn't hold arguments
what okay so i do this and then i say
multi equals percent
uh i'm not sure even that will work
in fact i don't think that will work
no no it won't even that won't work
oh no okay oh no it's because
oh you can you can look at this object
but i don't think it works
i'm totally confused
but multi has up values so that any
function you apply to it it eats
so you need to so including set so you
need to use unevaluated around it in
order to
set it to a variable
okay
clearly this isn't the right way to do
things and that didn't work
no because you didn't put this so you
just
you assign it to something
right so really there should be some
outer you know multi is the inner thing
and there should be some outer
wrapper which effectively is like
unevaluated i mean it's only real
properties that's hold first but
about why it's doing this i don't
understand why it did this well now
yeah i understand that but why because
it doesn't eat everything
well because it's intended as this not
just a hold of a rules but a bunch of
other things it's like you can
use it in any kind of expression and it
just
eats it up and
if you say two plus multi of three comma
five right like it has to be able to eat
the thing outside of it right
that's its whole point for existing
right but i agree
how do i see the result
how do i see the result
evolator
there you go
that's pretty cool
okay
okay so but the concept here is
this is
like something like listability
or sequence expansion
this is the thing that happens at a low
level in any expression and right now
it's a little bit unruly
because it you know unlike sequence you
know there is a sequence hole which
prevents sequence from just rampaging
all over everything
this thing can just escape and
and go over everything right now
is that fair
yeah like set has a sequence hold and
the rules have a sequence hold
that
because it's the common case
yes but in this case it's just it
doesn't happen
okay yep all right so i mean i think
that
probably i mean
the simplest thing would just be to have
some symbol i don't know what to call
you know multi-environment or multi-you
know enclosure or whatever you want to
call it and you know in the up value for
multi it just has an exception for that
one symbol where it won't that
or you just have a constructor here that
says
i mean i'm still a little unclear what
the semantics of this is this is a thing
that is that expression
but but there's an outer in this case of
two plus multi it's the outer
function
that is being
treated you know where you're kind of
those are two different constructors on
the screen right now
well they both say multi
right i mean well they're the same
you still can add two to this multi
variables you have
it will add a press placeholder to that
combinator then
they're different usages
okay but but okay fine but this one is
also one of these
uh
uh
you know instant explosion multis here
yes because the whole point is it's just
you know you it doesn't matter how you
create it you know if you have this as
you call instant explosion multi you can
still say two plus that and it should
eat the two and create a bigger multi
yeah okay fine but then what is this
doing in this multi
it just
well it's another it just provides a
list of rules it's specific to all it's
going to use
as opposed to just looking at down
values effectively yeah
which it could also do or could not yeah
it could also do if those s and k's were
just defined in the usual way
we're just defining down values it's
gonna just extract them properly
and only have a level
only go one level
when it extracts them because i mean
this thing
you know if i give a non-terminating
combinator
as it starts to extract it's just going
to blow up
well that's why you only extract it once
it just looks at where it can be applied
you close it then you just ask
how much
times you want to extract it or evaluate
it
okay it's not gonna export
it's just gonna take some time
okay because the thing it makes is just
an unevaluated thing and you have to
explicitly tell it to go some number of
levels of evaluation
yeah yes
in case if you had an actual definitions
there are cold versions of those
properties when it
stops
evaluation
just in case so let's evaluate hold
would be this thing where these things
are frozen by
its whole at least over eight apparently
okay
no no that sounds right but but um
okay
but now and the foliation that you're
using
in this kind of evaluate thing is some
kind of generational
evolution type thing is that right how
is it picking which ones
when you say
go ahead
everyday just relates
like all at once all space like
separated rules that can replace at once
they're going to fire it once but i have
a option only at once
that actually applies a single
replacement
so it will produce a list of all
possible expressions when you just apply
it once
but there may be multiple choices of
space like separated updates yeah
so what is it which one does it do
well even just doing the default
okay
okay
fine all right okay so that that will be
affected by the traversal order options
and things when when that is all hooked
up
yeah right now just uh whatever replace
part i guess is gonna do if you just
feed it all the
position and that in order for it they
will found
well wait a minute that's not right
because there can be overlapping ones
well you can replace part can have
overlapping one and whatever the first
one
is gonna
affect
over the last funding i think
okay
well i don't quite understand that but
anyway that's a that's okay so let's
take a look at this
so this is now saying
in
here
let me could we look at a a slightly
more i mean i i don't know what this
combinator does let me find one where i
do know what it does
um
i just want to understand what this is
doing here
uh
let's pull up a friendly combinator
um
all right let's pick this combinator
here
okay that one there
and now what i want to do
oh my gosh
multi-clicking is not such a panacea in
a case like this
okay so now what i want to do is
multi of graph
comma 10.
okay
the fixed point just repeating itself
then
okay so you might want a um
right a fixed point graph
notion
uh does anybody know where
where are we putting this um
[Music]
oh gosh
i don't know where this is going but
anyway
okay
so
okay that's encouraging that looks the
same
um
so for example if we were to take
uh
just to give a sense of the kinds of
things we might need right actually i'm
just curious how well this one does
i mean is this decently efficient or not
yours
uh
i'm not sure
i haven't spent much time optimizing it
let's see if i'm gonna go 20 steps or
something
humph okay so let's play some
okay
well it's plausible
a little different looking than this one
but anyway who's to know
all right i think i get it
so in this case here
um
okay lovely
all right so let me understand this
input here
okay so this was a multi
where these rules these are sort of
temporary assignments that are being
used here what does the all mean
uh it's a level
so you can
those rules can apply everywhere right
those rules are like there are the
second argument to replace and then the
all is the third argument to replace
basically
yeah
okay and this means replacing the heads
what does method arrow substitution mean
no that's
our three methods of strategy
substitutions because substitution or by
substitution
also should work
not in the case of combinations i think
but
yeah but
for those to work
this would have to be a pattern object
correct
yeah for those to be non-trivial that's
a pattern object
so i would like to say that i'm i'm very
keen for us to have a bunch of other
helper functions that deal with pattern
manipulation for which those
you know co-substitution by substitution
and so on those are things that should
be part of the family of functions that
deal with patent manipulation in
addition to being here
that makes sense i agree i agree
and in the end i don't think there
should be a methodology substitution
this should be just replace or something
here
and then you should also be able to have
you know co-replace or whatever the
whatever the right term is as an
alternative there
does that make sense
well yeah maybe right now
sorry said it again i mean
were you saying that you want a named
argument rather than an option
no i'm saying that i think the correct
version of this is
that that should be
okay that in a different world this
would be
multi of that and then this whole thing
just says replace
hash comma
blah
ampersand
that essentially what it's saying is
this is a multi
where at every step or maybe this isn't
the right semantics i don't know but at
every step this is the operation that
you're doing
so now it's a function so
you could just rewrite it as a rule it's
just x
goes to a place x sure
right but what i'm saying is that i'm
trying to understand what this multi
thing actually does
and what what you're saying is
that this is something that runs
in front of the evaluator is that
correct on an expression inside a multi
what do you mean
runs in front of
well i mean so so
let's say i said multi of two plus two
two plus three whatever
okay
okay i know how i do this something
that's pretty hard to use but but anyway
let's just say this
yeah i thought that's what it would do
you can wrap your
two plus three with another innovated
or withhold
no i understand but what i'm saying is
that what if you think about what this
multi is doing
it is at every step
it's multi-running the evaluator
or its version of the evaluator if i'm
understanding correctly
now it's by saying it's multi-running
the evaluator what i mean is
that
in
okay if i have two plus three four plus
five here
okay now i'm totally confused i'm just
irreducibly confused well
if you if you feed it at least it's a
little bit different
constructor you can
how do i get this out evaluate list okay
go sorry what we're going to say
you can just uh supply like a second
argument
empty empty list
because like empty lists of rules
and then it's going to be
at least going to be treated as an
expression instead
out of curiosity i mean
do these constructors work in a way
where like
you can do the list constructor but
quote unquote dynamically like could you
have something like
like here's a weird one you could write
like multi of select
of some list
and then maybe the the test for the
select is in multi as well if you get
what i mean so so the multi outer multi
can't tell until it evaluates the select
that its argument is going to be a list
yeah well
well it's going to treat it as an
expression
but it can be a list of some unevaluated
expressions
right okay i'm just wondering like can
he does does it need to know about the
list at multi-construction time and
needs to know its length and its
arguments or or can it sort of do that
in some weird dynamic magic way i guess
probably not well for this specific
semantics when you treat at least just a
list of alternatives and you have the
special number of values that it can
take then it had to be at least
from the on the construction
but so if you even say something like
here's an easy thing to write just say l
equals you know five comma six and then
say multi of l
what's that going to do is that going to
so again multi what
multi of right i guess i guess i kind of
know what this has to do like if you say
l equals five comma six and then multi
of l that's going to
do something multi is hold all is the
point basically and it's seeing
it's gonna
no no no l equals five comma six and
then multi of l
oh
oh so this is gonna do the same thing as
just the list five number six yeah
okay listen listen there's some problems
with the way this constructor works but
let's not get hung up on that okay i
want to understand the bigger picture
yeah
so
what does multi okay
what multi fundamentally does
is it's going to build up some data
structure here that represents
sort of this process of evaluation
this is a seed for the evaluation that
is sort of a trivial case of
of
a process of evaluation which is merely
the initial state
of two disconnected or n-disconnected
expressions is that right
yeah you can think of it like this i
guess
okay but then the actual process of
evaluation
done by the multi
in in in my way of presenting it here is
either the repeated i mean because the
default okay let me see if i understand
the default
is that we have an expression
and
although we don't really quite this
isn't quite the right name for it but
essentially we're just running the
evaluator at every step the default
evaluator at every step to determine the
result of
any
sort of branch of the multi is that
right
well not
no no no it's it's not trying to
evaluate like
by default it's extracting the down
values
that's the default behavior if you just
feed it an expression
and those down values
treat it as rules
so it's not really running the value in
the usual okay so it's running a fake
version of the evaluator it's running
a
a shadow evaluator
based on down values
and sub values and and own values yeah
right all of them okay did it work also
for like down code like if you do
you know no if you do no it will not do
that that's the whole point i have a
special option like
what pattern
just run as a down code
it's like well in this case it just runs
an actual creator if this if you find
this pattern just evaluate it
okay okay but you have to tell it what
things to like yeah so basically if you
say just multi of two plus two it's
going to be a little bit
confused like it's not gonna realize
that evaluates to four
yeah it doesn't know because there is no
doubt but if you provide a pattern
really plus then it will just gonna
emulate it into four
i see okay
okay but then then the second thing here
at least in this design like this
would be an alternative evaluator so
this we could call this
you know the the you know nick evaluate
or something okay or rules evaluate
let's call it that
rules evaluate
is a version of the evaluator that just
use them in principle we could have a
function rules evaluate that just does
this that switches up that might be an
interesting function it's on right
basically switches off it's only
it's
a
function
it's my multivariate function it's not
but this object uses it
as a workhorse
okay but
why is it multi-value as opposed to
rules i mean
if i'm understanding correctly there's a
version of this in which one could have
defined you know if it's rules evaluate
of f of g of x
f of g of one or something
but no no actually let me let me be more
precise here let's say
it's
f of two plus two
rules evaluate f of two plus two
where rules evaluate doesn't evaluate
its argument but if there's a definition
for f it will run it
but it doesn't run the down code plus
is that correct that that's what my
multi-volume does
but because it's using the down values
that it suggests that it's like
replacement for evaluation
you wrap it with unevaluated
i'm sorry and
oh yeah in this case
it's
what the correct is this
whoa
we just haven't found any rules that's
why it was an empty association
okay
okay so it has a different behavior wow
oh
man that's pretty elaborate
what is that you can just
i'm just gonna delete this
okay so but but the point is that rules
evaluate
or whatever it's going to be but
multi-value it seems like completely the
wrong name because it's a it's the
multi-brand but it isn't they're doing
anything well there's nothing multi
about it
um but okay there's so much about
because those down values it's not like
the first one that can be fired in the
usual evaluator sense but it can be
applied in multiple ways in the the same
position
and the point replace list
you know there's all those multiness
okay fair enough does not use downcode
by default and
does not
uh
and only well okay
i mean it doesn't lead leave the fixed
point thing
if if nothing okay so this okay so what
you're saying is i think it has
completely the wrong name because i was
completely confused about what it does
i mean what this is doing is it's giving
you
the evaluation data
from
a multi-evaluation is that right
that is right all of the
right
it's like almost documented page you can
look it up
okay okay let's take a look
maybe it's a little bit confusing
by a little bit we mean okay that makes
it
okay
so this is what
okay so this is using
we've defined patterns and this is using
i mean again this is one of the
confusing things is there's so many
different things you might want to do
like making this tree
does that that doesn't merge so i see so
this one
merges okay okay so for example here
if i define
my favorite fibonacci here
so what would i do i would define
fibonacci of an
goes to fibonacci of n minus 1
plus fibonacci of n minus 2
and then i would define fib of
of 0 equals
1
and now i would say
oh gosh
what the heck is that
well you don't say that that looks right
now let's do five of two
i don't understand this
not correct it's applying rules without
evaluating anything of its arguments
just like the replacement okay okay fine
so
okay it's applying one-step rules see
the thing that's super confusing
is that in the system by default this
notion of an evaluator that takes only
user rules and doesn't take anything
else is absolutely not something we've
never seen before
except in replace itself
for making sense
that's what i think is really confusing
and i think it's probably a mistake and
i think that for the time being it makes
more sense to support this kind of thing
without trying to get any of this kind
of you know
automatic
sort of eating of things i think
because i think this we could understand
what it's doing as soon as it's doing
this auto eating everything's out of
control
i think the whole point of the auto
eating is like
you know this is this thing you have
here is fine for combinators but it's
not at all it's not useful for you know
for programming all right like if you
want to write an actual program you you
need to have the eating all right so
let's let's understand how this works
all right so we've we've more or less
got what's happening in the combinator
case
and in this case what we're saying is
in right i think the thing the way to
think about it is the multi-object
represents like you know a
non-deterministic
you could think of it as just
representing like a non-deterministic
program right and so if you if you apply
something to the outside of it you're
going to get another sort of
non-deterministic program
which is why it's there program or is it
a non-deterministic expression
expression i mean or right i'm not sure
what the difference is smart expression
because it contains
all the
metadata
about how to relate itself
so maybe it's like a program
right but but i think
right i think
but it's also a lazy non-deterministic
expression
in the sense that it didn't actually
evaluate itself
yes
yep but there is a a function that you
could imagine that just says give me the
fixed point multi
from a given thing well it has all these
different methods right so that would
presumably be just one of the methods
yeah
right do you have that
fixed point not yet but it's
having a graph and
it's very close
okay just a matter of actually doing it
yeah okay so if there's a lazy
non-deterministic expression and then
you know example of an operation
evaluate to a fixed point
and of course it might not have a fixed
point and it might have three fixed
points and so on but that's one type of
thing you can do is evaluate to a fixed
point
right so out of curiosity i mean just
just to see what it's like to write an
actual program with this that's not like
a super
you know
patterny thing can you try just writing
something like
like um try try writing a uh
select of you know range of 10
and then for the selector
just do multi of even q comma odd cue or
something like that select
range of 10
and then multi even cue odd queue in a
list
right
yeah
that's interesting
okay so now what do i do here so i want
to get um
evaluate
at least
hmm cool
that's very cool that is cool
and you can see because of the way i
mean because we constructed the multi in
a you know in this way it can also tell
that it has two values right but and
maybe you could do something also like
the range maybe make the range multi of
10 comma
uh yeah yeah let's try it maybe yeah
make the multi there right
it should have four values now
cool
let me look at the graph for this so
percent 384 so let's what other things
can we look at here
this is actually just like a
only one step
i think
for the values case it's always going to
be like this
maybe there'll be a starter
yeah well let me just see let's start
off with one okay let me let me see what
what the um
um
let's see what is it called just graph
oh yeah well maybe for the values it's
not really i haven't tried the
graphs with values
okay to try just because this is the
thing i was trying to figure out earlier
is what happens if if you do um
instead of multi of 10 comma 15 if you
do multi of say range of 5
right so the point is that the range has
to is going to evaluate to a list
and that's going to possibly work
yes it does amazing
well that's the original motivation for
to doing something like this
and then to support downwards and graphs
yeah and all the rules
i do i do still think though that there
should be some outer rapper that that
even if it is just equivalent to
unevaluated there should be some outer
rapper that's like the you know
you know the the the whole intent i
think
this thing multi itself i think maybe
i'm wrong i think it should just not
evaluate here and that what what should
happen is that this is
uh you know there should be a
multi-evaluate two whatever you know
multi-evaluate x
that that puts that takes this
expression that otherwise you can just
put multis in and manipulate and do meta
programming with multis to your heart's
content because they're absolutely inert
and only
make it do something
when you put the whole thing inside a
multi-evaluate well i'm
because if you say select of a range of
multi or whatever the select is going to
try and run
i know i know but as an
attribute
presumably this needs a hold attribute
or you need to give the argument
unevaluated well no the multi-evaluate
xx absolutely needs to be held to hold
its argument but then what i'm
suggesting is that the typical use case
would be you build the thing with multis
in it
i don't know but this this doesn't make
it any easier to do anything though
because because already you know if
you're in an environment where
evaluation is being suppressed
then
you know then the multi that eats
everything you apply to it also won't be
running yeah all right okay right so
yeah
but okay so let's just understand okay
so let's
i want to look at the logic programming
example and i want to think about
examples where
you are
doing a
uh some kind of combinatorial
searchy type thing like is there a multi
applied to a graph that walks through
and generates all the paths in the graph
um is that a simple multi-story
it should be right because it's just
going to be the it's just going to
basically say what's it called you know
adjacency list
of you know the current vertex
it's going to say and then multi of that
and then it's going to recurse
right so let's try it
let's say
you need to do it with a dag for that to
work i would think
well loop
yeah yeah but well
this thing you you already tell it how
many times to evaluate right so maybe it
will
i don't know maybe not
let's try it okay so there's a graph
yeah they're just two different
graphs both are defined
what
i was just going to say
go ahead or for the dag case and also
where you just have adjacency list and
you might loop
yeah right let's do the might loop case
okay
of adjacency list
let's call this
okay so ggr
of hash
and then we want to say what do we want
to do here we want to say nest
list maybe
this thing
comma what do we want to do we want to
start with that is that right well maybe
you start with just a no list around the
one just one so think of the multi as
random choice
right if multi was random choice
yes then it should you know yeah right
then
one path
let's just try just for my elucidate you
know
let's try making this random choice
that's very cool perfect okay
all right so now let's go multi
so is this multi-evaluator this is
whoops
yeah that's tricky
well hold on so
yeah i know this is a very there are
several things going on in this case but
but when you do the multi-evaluator
where you just give it a list
and then you ask it to evaluate is that
using the normal evaluator though
because in that case it was calling down
code like when we had it calling select
and so on well if you just give it a
list here just ability the list
but no but sorry i mean like like i
think maybe i was confused but i thought
earlier you were saying
um
and when we had the combinators example
above that if you just said multi and
then you gave it an expression on the
inside that that expression it would
sort of take it apart it wouldn't
evaluate the normal evaluator on it
would use its own sort of special
evaluator that only could see you know
down codes own codes
values of values but but if you have
stuff outside of the multi that stuff
that's outside of the multi doesn't get
evaluated with that special evaluator it
just goes to the normal evaluator
no just though it will make this similar
thing
it just bubble itself up even from
in
it was still gonna bubble itself up the
multi from any expression
if it's not a health argument so i think
in this case it's tricky because
uh you have to hold your argument for
the muti because probably it just
explodes at each nesting step there
it's like inside somewhere inside of the
definition of nest list
now so this ampersand function should be
something like hold all complete you
know for it for to work
um
sorry say that again which has to be
fold all complete that um ampersand
function
the argument to the next list
maybe
well okay
i'm not sure that will work either but
but the concept here
nick do you believe that this concept
i mean
up to the issue of how this all works
for the evaluation semantics which i
think is a mess
but
you think this concept should work
that is that what i should get out here
is a sequence of multis
where the multis represent essentially
the gdc balls in this graph
is that correct
well if you just want the sequence of
multisensor it's really confusing maybe
because as soon as you have a list of
multis is gonna be going to make a list
of a multi-off list
yeah
you want a single multi anyway i mean
you want a multi that basically
non-deterministic you know
just as multi of 5.6 is sort of a
non-deterministic thing it's either five
or six this this should produce a new
multi that itself represents
non-deterministically some path of
length five starting at vertex so an
example of something we need to uh
you know we need we need some kind of um
uh multi-union
because clearly we're going to get a
multi here that we we both have maybe
you already have this it either it's
both got path counting and it's got a
union
mechanism well isn't just multi of list
and then give it two multis that should
generate the union of the multis right
no but i'm i'm saying that if we do this
right that's got six values but i might
want that to only have three values
because if i was doing some some
kind of sure yeah
you know that's an equivalencing in the
multi-way graph
that we might need or another example
would be if you imagine running length
of the nest list
multi then it should just return a
single value of five
right because they're always gonna be
like five
maybe yes
maybe
but but look the more important thing is
that
as this thing non-deterministically
trees itself out
we may very well want a situation where
it's equivalencing things and where the
multi-way graph well i mean
see what's happening here
i don't understand why this thing didn't
combine a bunch of those values
because in this graph it is combining
them well okay we might want
okay
sometimes we want the values combined
sometimes with their multiplicity kept
that make sense i mean that's the kind
of path counting versus not
nick you get what i'm saying oh sure
well it seems like just some post-step
processing yeah i agree probably so
except that we might want that to happen
an ongoing basis during the computation
to avoid the thing blowing up like crazy
right
i'm not sure how you would do it in
general but yeah we can make some
options that we mean
no if the things are the same
right if it's generating i mean it's
like in this case
that there's mergers in this graph
but the semantics of multi
does not account for that merging
until it is extracted in a graph you see
what i'm saying
no it's like you're running multi
generationally so you run
your multi once you get a list of
results if you have duplicates just
remove all the duplicates
no i'm not sure you should do it
automatically
right but okay but what i'm saying is
that that so you need some mechanism
multi-union something like that you need
something within the multi that tells it
at every step
if you generate duplicates get rid of
the duplicates
yeah
it's like a state
yeah it's some just option additional
that specifies what process and
post-processing steps you want to
perform
fine i mean it's like a deduplication
like a token deduplication or some such
other thing
sure yeah
okay but now
okay so let's take a look maybe at your
logic programming well let's see let's
look at the multiverse turing machine
first
essentially this it's essentially the
same example just
different
rules what's this weird thing here i
don't understand what this weird thing
is
it's a rule that just using
built-in steering machine evaluation
it's not fancy just a rule
it's not a
writing rule
as for combinators
it's just saying
that this is a single step
and this is combining
this is saying for a given step
so this says what do we apply the rules
to
i want you
no no forget the multi for a second i
just want to see a single rule
application
it's this right if we say rules of that
no rules i'm i'm completely confused
here
replace replace with this
what is that i think it's just the first
rule if you want all of them to be
replaced list
okay but what are these these are states
of the turing machine the position the
head state et cetera is this like what
the turing machine function does
yeah yeah that's what it accepts there
okay fine
okay so this is a one step in the
evolution of a turing machine
i'm pretty sure by the way that you can
just say turing machine
of
that that has a um an operative form
to a machine
just for what it's worth you don't need
to say state comma one
pretty sure if you say turing machine
one three three seven
no but i'm saying no no i feed it not a
rule i'm feeding it a um
well the number
yeah
there's its rule but now i'm just saying
that i think you can give it
really
oh come on
show me an example
of a construct
there's an operative form that
corresponds to one step resolution
why there's no example that i have no
idea
okay fine
so rule often at least with cellular
automata the one step evaluation thing
is also return a bunch of
like information about the padding and
stuff like that of the
of the yes um yeah
okay but anyway so so this is
now the same kind of thing this is
making my multi-way graph for a
multi-turing machine great
yeah and this is an example a little bit
different just because you actually want
your right hand side to ovulate and if
you try it with some hold properties
which i didn't show for some reason
that would like
yeah i know this is a mess i'm telling
you this thing with evaluation is a mess
i really think that the right way to do
this
i look i admit i don't really know
because these things are very nice
if we can make this really work
but we also want the case for these
other more symbolic things where we
don't want auto evaluation but we just
want to use the rules i'm giving you and
don't have all kinds of crazy
encrustment to prevent evaluation
so the cool thing is if you can write a
little bit of code like with rules and
then you can
wrap stuff around it on the outside and
and have that work too
right
yes i agree
okay let's look at this logic
programming example
it's like the basically the first
example from the wikipedia page
i haven't really put some
much thought to it but
okay
the only thing that is weird and i don't
know how to do it you have to specify
this last rule explicitly
when the things are false because in
prog for example you just all the rules
that you don't specify
are assumed false right if you have a
pattern that doesn't match anything it's
kind of false already
and i'm not sure how you do it
explicitly what exactly you should do
okay let's let me understand this
example so
in general
i'm so confused here
this is an expression and this is a rule
what the heck's happening here
oh no no i'm sorry
can fly is this so everything is a rule
yeah correct
right and
and so what we're asking is
uh
okay we want a series of rule
applications
but isn't the point
like
in prologue is you ask for
something here and you want to derive
right
you know
that's all that also kind of supported
a little bit because now
the instead of substitution
by default is by substitution
so actually so so this x was actually
bind it to something
so it should be
some kind of edge tag for that
so like the first h has a tag which
that has this information
of x binding to something else
so actually you can trace the graph and
see
the solution to your question in program
logic programming
the solution for x in this case
and why is this not a token event graph
why are the why are the transformations
not i mean okay you could think of it as
an edge label or you can think of it as
some kind of bipartite thing
um
yeah you can explode each into event
i don't think it's necessary here
because we don't have rules it's
necessary when you have left hand side
containing more than one token
you have just one token it can be well
represented by
the
biograph itself with some edge tagging
um
ah
sorry um sorry i got spaced out for a
second here could say that again i'm
sorry i lost that
about tokens
no i'm i'm okay
let's understand
again i thought like the end queen's
problem which i'm not even sure i
remember exactly what it is
but that's like a classic logic
programming problem problem i mean i
like to see one that isn't one of these
syllogism-ish ones
that is more bulk than this
if i'm making sense
difficult examples come later
but again okay i can imagine that it's
the state would be in the whole
chessboard
right
and yes just over just a list of
positions
it's just the problem just have to be
stated in this way
but i guess logic programming is just
the same as the rule programming it's
just a list of rules in any case to what
extent could we do okay so let's
remember the towers of hanoi thing that
we just did for the metal mathematics
project
could we do that with logic programming
how depends what you want there it's
like a solution for
what
well i'm saying
okay let's try to solve one of these
problems so we've got here
a um
you know we've got some proof
um
well okay
in this case we're saying
get from this configuration to this
configuration for example
i'm making sense
sure
and it should be the case that just with
with essentially multis
it should be easy to specify this
because the multi is just
you can put
this disk either here or there
yeah
um
strangely i was supposed to be we were
looking at this multi-way games thing
and that was actually the meeting that i
am missing right now i have missing
right now
um
um
uh because i'm thinking wouldn't that be
a good example of this in other words
this is a straightforward
or you know the tic-tac-toe case or
something like that it's a
straightforward thing where there are
multiple outcomes
and we have a question which is can you
get you know the logic programming
question is can you get from here to
there how do you do that
does that make sense
is it the logic programming question
i thought it's like more
over
a particular
module program is like asking for a
variable that satisfies you some of
those some of the constraints
well okay but i think you can ask i mean
those are different things you might
want you might want the path
okay what are the different things here
because this is what we're trying to
inventory right so one class of problems
says there are multiple things that can
happen at each step how can we get from
here to there
that's kind of like theorem proving
right we can we could do that the
theorem proving is like a replace list
at every step with some you know axiom
application
um and i think logic programming is the
same thing but as soon as you find
a path that you are looking for that
leads to true for example what variables
to what
values your variables are assigned to
okay maybe invariable if you can i i
wouldn't quite phrase it that way
logic programming is more so if they're
improving is pure path generation or
path finding logic programming is
allows you to solve essentially partial
versions of that same problem
so logic programming allows you in
general to say given this proof what
were the axioms or you know given this
theorem what
you know what what what
given this theorem and this partially
constructed proof path what's the rest
of the proof path look like things like
that you know that's really what gives
the power of things like mini cameron's
uh evalo
um
command
is the you know the ability to
reconstruct
partial proof paths and things
um
yeah so so hold on so so is it the case
because i mean one of the things that is
uh you know is one of the design
problems is right now multi-way system
has this giant
fiesta of different kinds of options and
things you can ask for
and one of the things we're trying to do
is to make that you know factor that a
bit
so what you're saying is let me try to
understand i mean so in general with
just find replace path which is sort of
my favorite minimal function
you're saying so jonathan you're saying
that
in standard theorem proving you're
trying to do a find replace path
in
you're saying in the logic programming
case can you compare that again to find
replace path what you're actually doing
yeah yeah so imagine the case where you
have part of a path
and part of the goal and you want to
reconstruct what's the rest of the goal
and the rest what possible
other parts of the goal and parts of the
path are consistent things like that so
so you know with with something like um
alpha cameron you can you can use that
to do theorem exploration because you
can partially specify a proof and
partially specify a theorem
um and then just have it explore
possible consistent things that fill in
the gaps
well so for example it would be a case
let's say with combinators you could say
um does there exist an end point that is
less than 20 combinations long
or show me all the endpoints the less
than 20 combinations long unlike with
theorem proving where you say i want to
get to this particular endpoint
you're giving some constraint on
endpoints and asking for
for
all such things would that be an example
yeah yeah sure sure
and so i suppose that you know the logic
pro if if find replace path is kind of
the minimum theorem the minimal theorem
proving case uh something like explore
replace path or enumerate replace path
would be the minimal logic programming
case
well or where or where you do find
replace path but where the end point of
the path
is a pattern
right right but that again that only
that only captures some of it right okay
you'd want a version of find replace
path that can take in a partially
specified path as well or a fully
specified path
and so your points are
find replace path
could have
i mean in which case find replace path
usually because look
okay again to make the comparison with
with um
you know with the symbolic mathematics
there are kind of two limit cases of
logic programming one is the theorem
proving case and one is the proof
checking case
right
okay
so so the theorem proving case is pure
pathfinding
the proof checking case is you're given
a path let me check the you know check
the endpoints
so you're given a proof and let me check
that it actually proved the theorem you
claimed it did
and then logic programming allows you to
do both of those endpoints but also
everything in between
i'm still a little bit lost i mean
you're saying
if i've given the path i know everything
that's on the path
so why is there anything else to do
what do you mean if if you're just given
a sequence of symbolic transformations
the problem of determining that those
symbolic transformations yields the
result it yields a certain result is the
problem of proof checking yes that's
what that's what that's what proof
function does in fine equation or proof
yes
right so so my point is that proof
checking is the other kind of limit case
that's the case so theorem proving is
the thing where you know everything
about the goal and you know nothing
about the path
proof checking is where you know
everything about the past and you know
okay and then logic programming is
everything intermediate
fair enough
fair enough
but okay let's come back and we
unfortunately have to wrap fairly soon
here but let's come back
to
okay i'm still i still think we have not
adequately factored what multi can do i
think this this whole eating versus
you know whatever isn't isn't quite
right yet
but the very interesting thing here
is you're basically saying you can throw
a multi into any computation
and okay with respect to those
evaluation graphs we're looking at last
time
um
we can have the single way evaluation
path we can have an evaluation path
evaluation graph
when there are multis inside which will
be some much more elaborate thing which
is also what you're getting from the
graph property of the multi
um
but right right
if you had a multivitamin just in place
of a vertex and a graph it would just
mean
several versions of this graph
yes
yes
but
with the understanding that
representationally
you know
for example this whole question about
duplicate elements in a multi
representation there may be things where
it should auto
reduce itself so to speak
if that makes sense right because you
don't want to blow it up with a giant
tree all the time
i suspect the reason why these things
were slow is because it's it's blowing
up to a giant tree and only reducing it
after the fact
right well not bone maybe well it's
generating all the edges in any case
it's
even the graph is even when the graph
did duplicate in your vertices you still
want to see all the edges that
were produced the same vertex
fair enough so there's no there's no
missing information here
no i understand but i'm i'm saying
i understand this has all the paths in
it but i'm i'm saying that i think
well i don't know exactly what you're
doing there but but
but somehow
i mean this is where we get into the
whole foliations question of what
not well
yeah i mean there's also the foliation
question of how you know
okay in our evaluator we don't have
affiliations question but we do we just
picked a particular foliation and then
we iterate until we get to the fixed
point
but
for this multi-way stuff it is going to
be much more common for us to not want
to iterate to a fixed point not least
because there may be many fixed points
or no fix or well it just doesn't go to
a fixed point at all so we need more
detailed control there
yeah like one of the ideas that i have
not implemented yet because
when you have a generational graph like
this you're essentially
uh iterating that
multi-list evolute property that you
have on the left for example right each
each
result from this property just results
in a list of results
so
in principle you just can't specify a
path as a just a
list of integers how to move
in this
list of lists
yes
so you just ask for multi
some take it give it a part and it will
just give you a result
as a single path
when you just turn arbitrary each time
well you're saying
that in a multi-way graph
you can think of it like a tree
where at every level you pick which
which branch
to take is that right
yeah
but this is like a lazy tree
yes
it's not evaluated yet but you give it a
part and it know how to turn each time
and if there is no enough turn you raise
an error or something
i'll do something more clever
okay
let's we need to wrap up but what's some
uh
um
do we want to define some next steps
here
um
oh yes
um okay so the to me
there's a bunch of i mean there's some
pretty heavy lifting design around this
multi thing that has to be done
because it's not you know
i'd really like to see i mean it's great
to see the combinator examples and so on
because those are somewhat
sort of real examples
i'm still not confident i mean i don't
know we presumably can write a sat
solver easily with this
can we not
it's just a
we just take an original expression
how how do you write satisfaction
probably the world's worst sat solver
but of course it will be but i
understand but we can at least see in
principle how it works
i guess just for each variable you want
to kind of
non-deterministically pick true or false
with multi and then
and then just
look i guess
yeah i guess there needs to be some way
of being like you know a multi dead end
right
for that to work
right because that that's you you're
going to generate this multi and you're
going to it's going to non-determine if
you took something but many of those
non-deterministic choices you want to
sort of
prune out
because they're because they're going to
get rid of something like this and then
we'd have um and then what we would do
is for every one of those variables
oh gosh how the heck do i do this
right how the heck do i do this i want
to replace every one of those variables
by multi true false
why you just say p arrow
multi
or replace all p arrow multi true false
q because because the multi is going to
eat the whole world
that's what it's supposed to do
well it's a rude wait then it's fine
i think it should okay okay so pro
i i i feel like it's supposed to eat the
world though i mean that's uh you know
i don't know what else you would expect
okay now what do i do
wait why did those monkeys not oh cause
and this is this whole let's hold all
really yes because it needs to be able
to short circuit like like if you give
it true it doesn't evaluate the
subsequent arguments
okay so but in principle
this what you see what's interesting
about this is if you think about the
observer on this
the satisfiability observer simply has
to ask is there any true in here
it's a slightly different case than
we've seen in other places
you know as opposed to the theorem
prover which says is there any ins well
it was a little bit like the um
um
uh
okay
um
all right i think we should wrap up for
now
um
i'll be on a livestream ask is it
helpful to think of multi as a general
purpose vectorizing container i'm not
sure it's i mean in the end hopefully
in a in a you know
future world
um perhaps we have the possibility to
you know
you know
implement this somehow in the compiler
with all kinds of all kinds of different
stuff
um
the uh
okay
um all right let's let's wrap this up
then um
all right well to be continued lots of
lots of interesting things going on here
um
uh unless anybody has one last last
comment anything else
nope okay until the next time